at this point right my left hand as you
can see here is kind of up anyway and if
this slap let's say this left hand his
right my left we're to come around here
to try and slap me in the head I do not
need to duck my head below the level of
the slap I only need to duck my head
below the level of this broad right here
okay I'm glad to be here with my half a
Schindler ng Morgan you know we get a
lot of requests often for behind the
scenes kind of some inside baseball but
none more than from the recent
installment of a change of mind actually
well not to change my mind but without
wendice for ian's we can use that term
when dis for Ian's attack yeah because I
was assaulted not once but twice man by
angry transgenders can you explain from
it Brooke assault versus batteries
assault is the bad one and latter is the
good assault it depends on this it
depends what state so in Texas assault
is when you've given the apprehension of
being battered battery is the actual
physical connection like when you sow
assault is the better battery assault is
that you didn't hit him but they were
scared about being hit yes but again the
battery it's a better battery you have
to pick right one exactly better one yes
exactly you didn't get hit in the
assault one I'm confused yeah okay do
you guys have you guys see me I have for
context for people who are who are just
coming in right now I highly recommend
that you go and watch the I shouldn't
highly recommend my own videos you want
to be very I would highly recommend it
go and watch the videos as well as the
change my mind for more context because
this is pretty much just silliness
there's not a ton of value added here
other than some incredible entertainment
which I thought was worth it that's what
they came for because my pride was I
mean do you have any idea how terrible
it feels to be assaulted by transgenders
and not be able to do anything because
you know that you would immediately be
hauled out in cuffs that even though I
have a half asian lawyer bill Richman on
retainer
he can't stop he cannot stop the torch
mob of me so much as flicking the ear of
a gender dysphoria and that is
impossible
crime the SPLC will be here yep all
right but let's walk you to just because
there was some stuff going on that you
couldn't have been privy to and we'll do
a little bit of a play-by-play but here
since you guys haven't seen it is the
first time you're seeing the very first
salt at the woman's mark here we go
let's watch
[Music]
didn't even lose my cigar yes mr. James
Dean himself at that jacket see that I
returned to that is that it was a term
of endearment of course which women then
deemed sexist and desperately wanting to
identifies women transgenders also claim
it to be incredibly sexist a woman says
I think sweetheart is sexist and
transgenders like me Jim
me too absolutely right so this was this
was a man to woman male to female that
was a this is a woman this is trying to
understand you don't know unless we ask
it's usually pretty obvious that we
shouldn't play by the way ask every
large woman their preferred pronoun see
how that works out not gonna be well
there's a little bit of a play-by-play
here this is something that a lot of
people may not know but we do have
security obviously at these events
yeah but primarily my number one focus
is to avoid being harmed while still
staying safe and so sometimes it
requires that you defend yourself and it
requires creative ways of doing that
without harming the other person right
before we get to this this just goes to
show you the complete lack of
accountability from these people yeah
this male to female transgender walked
up and try to summarize private property
of even if you don't know me or you
don't just agree there pulp me and then
two other 220 pound men 700 pounds of
meat hey there's no way I like the balls
on earth if there were scrawny walking
prawn and Tifa
yeah no there's no way that you would do
that unless you knew that you had a free
pass and that's what they've been given
it by the way the police were right
there so in this instance there actually
was a little bit of sort of technical
maneuvering at play so let's replay this
clip here a quarter black here so we can
see okay so I see this person up
have my cigar - LaRon yo great cigar
look at this right away no he's going
for the going for the table and I'm
thinking okay alright I have to handle
this and okay let's free frame okay so
before we get to this really quickly
people I've seen some people say like oh
you need three people to stop one trip
no no we need three people to step one
transgender and not harm them great
right yes think about coming over the
top with that the whole thing is we
don't want to commit counter assault but
I did I was looking at this here so we
can pause really quickly so one thing I
want you to see is I don't know if you
saw this but right here okay I don't
know if you can see this that's right
see how my foot comes up off the ground
yeah so right away I know that this
gender dysphoria is yanking on that sign
and this person's weight is backwards
right right and I'm thinking okay I
don't want to let go of the sign now
what I do is I actually saw that the
weight was very heavy okay on this lead
leg right there so let me erase that let
me make it a little bit clearer so that
way I don't have to get in the way of
the line later so right there I can see
look back foot is up so we know the
weight is on this lead leg that is the
lead leg that I go for and just lightly
tripping with my foot why did I do that
well let me tell you why I did that
because when you tend to trip somebody's
leg and we'll get to that in a second
this person would have one choice right
they would either have to go
ass-backwards into pavement lovely bush
let go of the sign and rotate out and
credit to this gender dysphoria very
good balance probably would be good and
a wrestling meet at defending a single
egg probably was an all-state wrestler
before this what were you thinking like
when she this person I don't know how to
say the booth when they were coming up
like were you thinking this is somebody
who's coming up to sit down or were you
like oh no no I I knew right away and I
was entirely thinking okay how do we
make sure that this it's the only sign
we had yeah
did you see that beachy style walk up
yeah it's true a wrestler right how do
we how do we keep this sign and pry this
person off without them being able to
claim that we harmed them even though
they instigated something so again I'll
show you real quick okay foot comes up
and traps this foot right here this
person's choice is to go down into the
pavement or circle out 360 and if we
play it right now you can see what
happened I sweep the leg continue
pushing it up let's go of the sign and
circles out to avoid being off balanced
and then walks away see that little hop
that's to regain the balance there you
go this is the beauty technique circled
out into a wonderful little curtsy to
convince us all that you are a woman
I dare I dare and this is something
actually that we we practice quite a bit
and resilient it soo in Naruto for
people who don't know when we do it we
typically do it obviously not holding
you changed my mind sign yeah but you
grab a collar elbow and so when you do
this foot trip and you're actually
trying to take somebody to the ground
what you would do is steer them to the
weight of the leg that you're trying to
swing right basically now you catch that
foot and then when they try and step up
and step their foot out you sweep it and
you tip them yeah it's a very non
violent way of getting somebody to the
ground who's a threat or opening
something else if you're looking to try
and achieve a takedown as a matter of
fact one of my favorites ha drag race
you can see it right here it's called
the AH she buries a takedown performing
it against Rafael Lovato now watch the
way he circles he lifts up tread and
circles and goes down let's see that in
slow motion really quickly so it's the
exact same technique that was used at
the trench look now the foot comes up to
try and avoid it and the upper body
wheeling is what drives him to the
ground have said transgender right I
knew they were gonna either cling onto
that sign or let go yeah you did it was
a good thing nobody got hurt
so safe and I also think it's a good
it's a good thing to talk about when you
talk about self-defense right like what
are the other ways people tend to get
this idea that if you are a gun owner
right that you're just looking to for
any excuse to shoot someone but really
you learn a lot about how to deescalate
one of the ways that the escalate is to
be prepared to execute a move that
allows people to get away or allows them
to have the option right because if all
you know how to do is flail and punch
which a lot of you know the answer for
members do that's right and so inside
treat milkshakes
exactly then you resort to kind of a
crouching milkshake hidden concrete
watching Frosty's but that is what I
will say the reason I'm a big fan of the
grappling arts because it can be drunk
uncle Jiu Jitsu as I call it or it can
be something more severe it's basically
as severe as you want it to be if you
have to strike somebody you know your
only way of dealing with the situation
is hurting some of which in some
scenarios that's appropriate but you do
not want to deal with the legal
ramifications not to mention the social
justice ramifications and as you saw and
the change my mind the these people
they're especially this one woman I was
interviewing we're immediately quick to
forgive and accept oh yeah deme all
horrible behavior on behalf of
transgender is acceptable
thanks again saying I deserved it well
sign was asking for it spinner
saleswoman her oh yes we will get to
that in a second well no I just had a
comment it seems like because we've
removed all of these barriers like you
know as kids growing up you knew not to
get out of lined around certain guys
because you might get popped in the
mouth if you said something completely
wrong or if you did something really
aggressive towards them they might
defends himself maybe it was wrong
whatever right but you knew where the
line was now we have no idea where the
line is because people are doing most of
this stuff on social media they can say
whatever they want to say and then they
go and do this in public and it's like
now I have to treat you with kid gloves
I don't know if you have a knife in your
pocket you're gonna grab the sign and
then try to knife me right absolutely
would you by the way thank you for
bringing up that you know where the line
is because we're going to get in this
next one into the line of attack
and what you see is maybe just seems
like some kind of brilliant mocking that
I'm performing sometimes it's actually
really just a way of disguising
protecting myself again from being hurt
so let's roll this clip you guys I guess
haven't seen a scene of the next because
that was actually tame that was
positively what happened okay spoiler
alert it involves a hobos lunchbox being
thrown in oh no by the way there's no
defense for that every krav maga school
in the country no they'll show you had a
palm strike the nose all that stuff you
know stuff that you won't really pull
off but they you have no hobos lunchbox
defense they even have monkey grabs
peach you know what that is it's were
you oh I read it I read it in a ninjutsu
book that's not a joke that looked like
the spider-man all right so here is the
next gender dysphoria and there's so
many of them there showed up here while
we were interviewing this woman let's
say a cop or an attorney or whatever
that's what my student well what were
you wearing that night that permeates a
conversation serious just later this
happens to me four or five times and I'm
sick and tired of this debate may need
to respect women period so you should
respect women you're going to let me
speak because here's my truth lies I've
known women that have been raped
multiple times gruesomely and how dare
you sit up here and try to say that
women aren't worth a respect here
dancing
period and I'm me I'm already black so
it's just like yeah that already goes
against me anyways
but still avoid my piece of living
dumpster fire trash gum on the bottom of
my shoe god I wish I had a tissue for
the flood I would oh when I suggest it's
your behavior not because you're blacker
watch this your behavior this is I think
this is going to escalate to a point
where there might be some accountability
for this psychopath
not everyone just that one with a fidget
spinner oh my god and lest you doubt me
you will see why I say I believe that
that person was mentally unstable also
we were informed that that person was
mentally unstable and we're kind of
joking but listen we've had some really
dicey scenarios keep in mind for those
who've forgotten we for went to Virginia
gun rally because we thought it would be
too dangerous
but there is a certain level or there's
a certain distance with which I'm no
longer comfortable when people come in
and this person came in hot so let's
replay this and I'll show you what's
kind of going through my mind here and a
quart of oil pause debate maybe no
debate
period so you should respect women I am
the woman by the way you really didn't
know would you know that
okay so there we go sorry I was talking
before it looks come on right there take
you like let's a Letterman's jacket and
a fidget spinner and a carry-all can you
please give us a little help here so
right away I don't know if you notice
here this person is leaning in and
getting closer and closer so when we
start my hand is about right here okay
hmm
and this is something actually bas
Rutten is a front of the show we've
talked about this and he's done this
before
when I get to a certain level where I'm
not necessarily comfortable and make
sure and you see my hand go from there
to here why my microphone is right here
and you can actually see this bet if you
go back to the one-credit confronts with
a guy tried to hit me with the price all
right
this translates very quickly into being
able to protect yourself now it's not
kung fu wushu stuff where a fight is if
it happens is never pretty you're just
trying to not be hurt if someone
surprises you so let's go back here at
this point there was a point where I
realized when this person was leaning in
and yelling the hand emerges from the
table and comes up as you can see right
here why because of course I am looking
to protect my face and we'll come back
to that in a second also too this may
seem kind of trivial I don't know if you
notice this right here see the elbow is
right against the body and again that's
because this kind of instinct you don't
want someone to hit you in the body I'm
trying to think what is exposed right
here if this person tries to get
aggressive now you'll notice before that
when the this individual was further
away I was sitting here I was perfectly
comfortable once that distance is close
and I would highly recommend everybody
out there take some Brazilian Jujitsu or
some kind of a realistic sporting combat
art jujitsu wrestling judo boxing Muay
Thai kickboxing that's pretty much what
works okay because you'll be able to
practice this all the time and it's
about staying safe it's not about of
course hurting anyone or using any
whatever martial arts prowess you made
it's just it's an athletic event at that
point I don't why people acclaim I have
your hands registered weapons no one's
hands are registered weapons Steven
Seagal hands are
sporks okay they play when you run yeah
so I think I want to play this again I
get even less comfortable as this person
leans in even more and so what you see
with this I'll explain to you exactly
what my hand took that position garbage
dumpster fire trash on the bottles of
the relationship well okay
for a couple of things here she said he
she she is saying this yeah because I
realized II was expecting this to be
like a clap back moment right and I
think he thought that everyone around
would agree with with is March right
right
and it was silence there's like piece of
garbage dumpster fire surfer and then
just going until Z realized that there
was not going to be any sort of app no
support none of those landed now at this
point though you can see Z's more and
more leaning in closer and closer so at
this point I'm a little bit concerned
that was the breath this is where I
start doing that as you see my fingers
my hands rotating I'm doing a little bit
of this now yeah why why did I do it
with my right hand couple of things here
that are important to note okay I'm
going to switch this actually to a red
stylus to make this a little bit easier
here's what I thought and this actually
did occur to me at the sound like okay
this person is probably not going to be
throwing straights straight down the
pike right cross I'm imagining it's most
likely to be a slap slabs come in kneel
on the perch they come in on the
periphery so at this point right my left
hand as you can see here is kind of up
anyway and if this slap let's say this
left hand his right my left we're to
come around here to try and slap me in
the head I do not need to duck my head
below the level of the slap I only need
to duck my head below the level of this
broad right here
[Laughter]
yeah the primary force of that blow now
quite is she is she this person in the
chair and liberal I'm assuming based on
the behavior so this would be a very
good shield to use right okay
got it yes well I wasn't looking to use
a [ __ ] zooming via to vet this person
wouldn't want to fight a lie but
considering that later on this person
ended up stealing a hobos lunch box yeah
seems as though that wasn't their
primary concern okay so again I was
thinking this isn't coming straight down
the pipe you know straight right cross
and if that happens all I would need to
do of course is lean back because
there's a table in the way so we've
eliminated the risk of straight down not
only because of the table but
transgender probably gonna be a slap
let's be honest very limp wristed we've
eliminated the risk of coming over to my
left side because let's assume this is
the lady's head on this I would just
need to get below that yeah level you
can't really see because of the depth
but right there I'm already below it's
like that I don't need to outrun the
bear I just need to outrun you yeah
that's pretty much what happened so what
I was figuring here was the most likely
strike to come my way would be that
Louisiana right coming around over to
the right side of my face there left
hand which would still require again a
big reach right a big reach over across
the table would be telegraphed and I
knew that if I had my hand up not only
was this saying get on with it not only
did it appear to be hilarious
in retrospect primarily concerning with
myself if this is the most likely threat
so I want to have this hand up to parry
do whatever I've got to do and fidget
spinner yes thank goodness I have no I
could have been a ninja star for all I
you you don't know with those yeah you
guys know yeah I mean she could have had
a concrete in that purse I'm treating
that purse
oh and that is also something important
to note I we now know that this
Tupperware container lunch box was
stolen from a hobo for two reasons one
because the Hubble was picking it up
afterward and was very clear that it was
these were his belongings oh and it also
part the belongings included a New
Testament which we know this individual
probably was
but even more than that I noticed you
actually know what we can go let's go
back to this picture can we go back to
this here let me get rid of all these
things I noticed while we were here look
the clutch because I can't remember what
this was but there was some kind of a
designer logo and we're looking at it
going oh that's a fake bag because the
zipper here only changed the font of the
color here the zipper which I could see
on this side was very poorly stitched to
all that is holy I noticed that the
zipper wasn't actually matching up with
the bag and so I thought this is
probably a relatively new gender
transition someone who's dazzling
because they haven't gotten the whole
toolkit yet that's right Sherlock crime
that became relevant when the hobos
lunch-pail but whatever it is this is
what I'm going with it's really one of
those things that you would put like
guys Crayolas in Incline like it was
this a homeless person I was just like a
train rioting bomb I'm like oh man he's
got a little stick with a bag on the
back yeah no I have a clock shadow he
didn't say you know the thing is now I
was saying hobo to save time but now
you've eaten it all up I just wanted to
make sure you didn't get any advantage
out of that yeah accomplished here and
let's not lose sight of the point is
there is no way that this package could
have been carried in this person in this
carry-on personally not supported yes
person was not gone nearly long enough
to go to any kind of apartment or place
where they could have maybe they could
have gone to their car
but again your belongings going into the
cruise you person took my Bible and my
hairbrush it was a Bible on hairbrush so
that's mean that's the story I'm going
with yeah and we have proof of that
there quarterblack care you have a clip
if I'm not mistaken we're after this
this transgender individual leaves and
you found the footage if we zoom in you
can see
that up me wow they're leaving this one
hold on
okay that's yeah that that's just more
liberating me here we go okay so then
the interview continues now ya know
hobo's lunch box no it's not there good
detective work very nice order black
carrot this is building the K now only
what would we say maybe maybe like ten
seconds later ten seconds later the
gender dysphoria
emerges once more quarter black carrot
let's show that clip you can see and now
right around the corner stand that if I
lived in another where there just so
happens to be a Clank miss and then
shuffle Steven Seagal school of
athletics ran off like you ever see the
movie gremlins too and that's the last
clip that we have so yeah and then after
that the the man was collecting his
belongings the unfortunately here's
something that actually is important
that homeless man didn't ask for this
lady who I was interviewing this
obviously far left third wave feminist
excused all of it all of it didn't say
word about it well no well yeah if you
go and watch she says well that was very
brave of by her to say that she had been
raped four times and with it's brave to
lie I mean we don't know if that's true
or not just to make a claim yeah and
then assault somebody and then afterward
when the lunch box was thrown I said I
just can't believe you're fine yeah and
you shouldn't good and I said that's not
very nice sweetheart
she's well you know you were good you
shouldn't have been goating it
at this point but all of it was entirely
excusable because we deserved it and
this is what's so important thing for
people to know and this is why it's
important for you to keep your head on a
swivel and stay safe if you are in these
groups and you'll notice this we're
going to release some more conversations
let's change my mind the white sis men
are so scared to speak because if
there's any kind of a confrontation or
disagreement they will immediately be
vilified oh yeah yeah and they know that
there will be no recourse they are in
the wrong this is the culture that has
been created here when you see this
right here yeah at every single turn its
hold on a second you're the white male
so you must be wrong so you need to
learn how to defend yourself how to stay
safe without even the perception of
causing harm to anybody else because
they're looking for you to be wrong and
they really want you to be wrong and
this was really disconcerting when we
were there to see this this kind of a
month it really just comes from the idea
that okay you establish this myth that
we live in a patriarchal society that we
that rights are afforded to men that are
not afforded to women and that all these
people are neo-nazis or white
supremacists or hate groups therefore
it's okay to the ends justify the means
right even if I steal an object from a
homeless person provided that I am
whipping it at a sister white male who
disagrees with me and no one will do
anything happens all the time well and I
think she probably would have been mad
at you had you not come to her defense
if this woman had targeted her right
right if this woman had come after her
and something like she probably would've
been like help me who came after who the
transgender comes after the liberal who
you gotta be care for that why didn't
you stand up for me well I just didn't I
thought you were in the wrong I yeah I
and I don't even know I mean if I would
have ever filed a police report I mean I
also wonder this person came up and said
I am newly a woman and I was raped four
times which mayor
not be true which means you got it right
to begin with because you called her out
on that but the thing is first off okay
if I had a gun to my head I would lean
toward probably not four times ya ask
the question when did this individual go
from male priviledge to now female
victim status and they weren't able to
give me an answer they said whenever
this person claims so I now understand a
solution to this problem whereas I've
been training and I pay all this money
to have security go out there to keep me
and my crew safe what I need to do is go
out slap on some Rouge and a tube of
lipstick and just claim that I am a
woman and then slap people and steal
this best what you want to know how do I
know
women's marches and feminists so well I
picture a man and then remove all reason
or accountability to the channel hit the
notification bell if you're already
subscribed to this channel because that
lets you know when new videos come out
and they don't show up on the youtube
search feed also there are videos
playing in boxes here click one of those
just of all the things that I just
mentioned all you have to do is one and
if you don't I will run for the United
States presidency under the one one
thousand sixty four percent Cherokee
Party I have yet to pick my VP